the president of Brazil's being dubbed
the Trump of the tropics as me for his
right-leaning views and indeed he chose
the United States as the destination for
his first official foreign visit to
jumpstart the relationship I also know
that we're gonna have a fantastic
working relationship we have many views
that are similar and we certainly feel
very very true to each other on trade I
think Brazil's relationship with the
United States because of our friendship
is probably better than it's ever been
by far respect whatever the ballots tell
us on 20/20 but I do believe Donald
Trump is going to be reelected fooling
folk you know pasados in Como thank you
for your factory meats began on a cheery
enough note the two leaders exchanging
football shirts with each other's names
on all this might come as a relief for
Jay Abbas Niro who's currently facing a
political scandal at home of a reports
of his alleged ties to violent gangs KLM
opens got more on the allegations back
at home
Boston ro is facing a pretty serious
political scandal not over his words but
over his ties to right-wing paramilitary
groups something Brazil is notorious for
[Music]
earlier this month two former police
officers were arrested and charged with
the killing of Marielle Franco a
left-wing elected official now when the
police raided the home they found 117
automatic rifles as well as computers
full of intelligence information on
left-wing journalists activists and
politicians so where was this mini
command center of extremism located well
it turns out it was on the same block as
bolson arroz home in fact a photo of
bowls an arrow with one of the suspected
killers has surfaced when confronted
about it Boston ro gave a flat-out
denial Nina that has always criticized
me they wanted to establish a clear
connection but I've never saw that
gentleman in my gated community I don't
really spend that much time to you know
engage in social life with them this is
not the only tie to extremism back in
January 5 former leaders of a right-wing
gang were arrested and it was revealed
that the wife and daughter of one of the
gang leaders was actually employed by
balsa narrows son Flavio son of the
Brazilian leader joined his father in
taking a photograph with the gang
leaders at a birthday party furthermore
Flavio also gave an award to one of the
gang members a Medal of Honor now there
was an incident back in 2011 that also
raised suspicion a judge was murdered
after a controversial trial and we heard
this interesting statement from balsa
narrows son may this judge be with God
but the absurd and gratuitous way she
humiliated police officers and court
sessions contributed to having many
enemies so when balsa Naro sat down with
Donald Trump he had some pretty serious
charges hanging over his head a lot more
serious than say unreleased
tax returns now Boston ro before he met
with Donald Trump sat down with another
powerful US entity the US Central
Intelligence Agency
the cia's ties to right-wing extremists
and death squads in South and Central
America is hardly new information and at
this point there's got to be folks
inside of Trump's team who are wondering
if his photo op with this right-wing
Brazilian counterpart is really such a
good idea
Kaleb Maupin RT New York well it's
always echoed by Brazilian political
analyst Bruno at Lima or Osho says even
having his photo taken with the militias
is a disgrace for the president the
family's president being seen in old
photographs not pictures with militiamen
with sportman is at least a shame for
the position of the president and the
presidency is elder son father boffin ro
was a state deputy in Rio de Janeiro
state because of the security policies
in Rio is very much it's much more
connected to state violence then to
public safety in a flag abortion are
himself has an exterior I employee
called Kay Royce in his staff that is
very accomplished it's very committed to
the I could say the hardcore band of
military police